[Music]
enemies to the east enemies to the West
enemies to the south enemies to the
north whatever stands in our way we will
defeat we're the last Lannisters
the last ones who count
I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will
[Music]
their father and brothers are gone yet
here you stand
last best hope against the coming storm
if we don't put aside our enmities and
band together we will die
and then it doesn't matter whose
skeleton sits on the Iron Throne
[Music]
the Great Wall is here
you
happy Game of Thrones day they finally
dropped the season 7 trailer there's a
new round of the game of Thrones
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video there are so many big beats here
so I'll talk about all the big stuff
then I'll go through shot-by-shot
so let's do this we jumped from Cersei
she gets dialogue then to Daenerys
talking about how she was born to rule
Cersei is making war then Jon Snow
talking about the wars to come even
Davos is talking about not coming
together we will fall the coming
darkness is too great is they show you a
bunch of wildlings including Jon Snow
running through the frozen north so
we're going to be going all over
Westeros in ways that we've never seen
that's why they show you the maps at the
beginning of the trailer we saw with
Cersei walking into that table room you
get a shot of grey worm of the unsullied
all the different forces you see the map
table at Dragonstone when she's talking
about enemies to the west you see these
ships that's talking about the Greyjoy's
and their fleet there's a hand that
sticks out here it's got greyscale guess
who that is that's Sir Jorah he's back I
mean we knew he was coming back but it's
so awesome that they show that bursts
like they don't show you his face they
show you the hand that's gotten even
worse and yes I do think that he's gonna
be a big presence in season 7 but it
looks like he has not found someone to
cure that yet and then you know we see
Cersei rally herself we will crush them
all as you see all these Lannister
soldiers walk by we've seen Lannister
armies but not looking this awesome so
far you see Jaime standing next to her
in the iron throne room Tyrion standing
out on the cliffs as he watches the
dragons rise up the dragons have come to
Dragonstone so they raised balerion the
black dread a bunch of other dragons
they are back in the time of Aegon the
conquerer so it is a natural ruse for
dragons there caverns beneath dragon
stone so hopefully we'll get to see them
you see Daenerys touched the beachfront
she's named Daenerys Stormborn because
she was born there but she hasn't been
back there since she was a little baby
they fled just as she was being born you
get a better shot of Casterly Rock the
unsullied just pouring in so this is
obviously on the other side of Westeros
so we're jumping around in time as we
jump through the trailer then you jump
to the shot of Jon Snow at Winterfell
but little
finger gets the voiceover whispering in
Santa's ear you're the last best hope
your father and brothers are dead so it
sounds like you get a couple shots of
him in the hallways it sounds like he is
definitely going to try and get Sansa to
move against Jon Snow Jon Snow looks
like he's down here in the crypts
getting ready to wreck him next to the
statue of his mother that he might not
know is his mother yet so either little
fingers gonna play with that idea or Jon
Snow is just gonna get tired of his
[ __ ] but I think that if someone's
gonna get rid of a little finger they
should give that to Sansa just because
it's so much more meaningful to her
character but Jon Snow just ain't gonna
be taking anybody's crap you start
getting more shots of the frozen north
this is the gated Castle black up at the
other side of the wall you see a shot of
Theon that looks like he's on one of
these boats in this big explosion here
you see all these big battles going on
this battle at the sea looks like it
gets a little help from the Dragons just
because this ship is burning so fast
more of arya making her way even further
north a lot of snow on the ground so it
doesn't look like it's gonna be too long
before she arrives at Winterfell
this shot of the Dothraki bloodrider
'he's riding into battle looks like it
might also be from this scene here with
him on this big field of engagement with
drogon rising behind them so all the
while jumping back and forth between
people looking at their maps making
their plants Daenerys in front of the
map table her ancestor Aegon the
Conqueror is the one that had that table
built right before the conquest not
really sure who arias trying to find
here but she might actually finally be
back in Winterfell looking underneath a
bed just trying to find things that she
may have hidden when she was a little
girl but one of my favorite shots here
is Jon Snow in the burrs running through
the frozen north there's supposed to be
a really big action set piece set around
the White Walkers late in the season so
this is probably what that's from you
get a little Miss and I and grey worm
action and then just riding into battle
the Great War is here so obviously he's
talking about the war with the white
walkers but you see new costumes for
almost everybody too near us at
Dragonstone you see the mountain in a
crazy-looking kingsguard version of
Circe's armor that she's been wearing
since the end of last season you get a
better look at the dragons and it almost
looks like Melisandre is going to be
with Daenerys
she's watching them walk up that winding
staircase now we know where she is it
looks like it's not gonna be too long
before she gets a reunion with Jon Snow
answer Davos if he comes to Dragonstone
with him so that reminds you of that
Davos line if we don't come together put
our differences aside we're all gonna be
dead but doesn't that make you wonder
what Circe's final fate is going to be
especially if Daenerys is going to sack
Casterly Rock this place that you
thought was untouchable for most of
Tywin's adult life is Lord of Casterly
Rock the Lannisters were untouchable
then you started seeing a couple of dead
children dropping like flies
Jaime got captured got his hand cut off
so they are being backed into a corner
but the really cool thing about Jaime
now is that he's not a member of the
Kingsguard anymore so he is Lord of
Casterly Rock and he's wielding widow's
wail one of the two Valyrian swords that
they reforged from the melted down ice
the great sword of Ned Stark so there
are a couple big reasons why they might
have done that George our Martin said
that in the books what happened is is
after Joffrey died they sent that to
Casterly Rock so we might get to see
Jaime there maybe that's where he grabs
that sword or maybe Cersei just orders
him to start using it but the really
cool thing here is that now that the
wars are heating up we might get a
moment where Brienne is forced to fight
Jamie with Oathkeeper so you wind up
with a situation with the sword of Ned
Stark fighting itself or even if they
fight together
you basically have ice between the two
of them so if they're either fighting
together they're fighting against each
other it provides for this really
amazing metaphor no matter what but I'm
really hoping that if Cersei goes down
and Jamie's the one to do it
he does it with widows wail how poetic
would that be you get the valonqar
prophecy don't know if the show's gonna
do that but we can all keep our fingers
crossed but ending her with the sword
that was forged for her son but just
jumping around in time you can see that
a lot of these conflicts in Westeros
especially Daenerys going after Casterly
Rock looks like it happens relatively
early in the season especially the
Greyjoy fights the stuff that's
happening way up in the frozen north
doesn't look like it happens till much
later in the season because of the way
they cut the trailer they talk
about enemies all around us we'll crush
them all so you have all these
engagements Daenerys is mostly focused
on taking the Iron Throne everybody is
concerned with the wars that are
happening in the south they're not
really concerned with the stuff that's
happening in the north with the
exception of Jon Snow in Davos now that
we see that Melisandre is with Daenerys
she might try to convince her of the
threat of the White Walkers and help
bridge the gap between her and Jon Snow
but we also know about maester Marwan
who does not appear in the trailer he
helps Samwell at the Citadel so there
are a number of characters that are very
concerned with the Great War in addition
to Jon Snow that can help convey a lot
of information to the other characters
they don't really know about that yet
especially as Cersei she has no idea
what's going on in the frozen north but
let me know in the comments what do you
guys think about all this and what do
you think it's going to take to get
Cersei to help out with what's going on
in the north or do you think she's never
gonna help do you think that they're
going to crush her and we'll wind up
with a version of Daenerys as vision
coming true with King's Landing in the
iron throne room just burned to a husk
with all this snow falling down winter
has come so obviously we're gonna be
talking about a whole bunch of this in
the next couple of bonus videos but let
me know what you want my next game of
Thrones video to be about that'll
probably post in the next couple of days
there's so much to unpack from this and
it's just the beginning you're gonna
start seeing a lot more of HBO promoting
Game of Thrones now that we're heading
into the summer less than two months to
go we're almost there so there will be a
lot of white Walker things happening in
the north and they even use the night
King to promote that motion post or a
couple days ago so they really want you
to be thinking about White Walkers even
though none of them appear anywhere in
this footage so I'll name the giveaway
winner when I post that longer video
while you wait for that you can click
here for more promo breakdowns and you
can click here to learn all about what's
going on up in the north thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys in a little while